i'm veterinarian dr molly mcallister and
this is my dog jack today we're here to
answer your questions on twitter this is
vet support
[Music]
at don't forget chaos asks why don't we
keep squirrels as pets we keep rats
rabbits mice etc why not squirrels i'd
like a pet squirrel no you wouldn't
squirrels do not make good pets they are
destructive they have teeth and claws
and they will chew things up squirrels
are not social animals in fact they will
turn on people including handlers who
have raised them from babies and number
three squirrels are not able to be
litter trained or trained in any way
shape or form all in all squirrels don't
make good pets stick with your dog your
rabbit your mouth or even a rat at
santeesha asks where do these
hair balls come from if you own a cat
you've certainly seen them grooming they
spend hours of their day quite literally
grooming themselves by licking the fur
that takes the loose hair and oftentimes
they tend to swallow that and rather
than digest it the cat's gi system
enables them to gather that hair up and
regurgitate it so they do spit it back
up and that ends up being the nice hair
ball that we find probably on our nice
carpet and that is just the nature of
cats so at laurie mercad
asks what causes obesity in cats and
dogs it's when the calories that they
consume exceed the calories that they
burn so it's a mismatch and how much we
feed them and how much activity they get
because we control that and then let's
make sure that they get lots of exercise
as well because it's good for all of us
all right at shumei asks why my sugar
glider have so many problems crying face
sugar gliders you know they are an
exotic animal they have some husbandry
challenges they require a unique
environment so that's number one here's
another big thing about them you know
sugar gliders glide therefore they love
playing and you've got to have a safe
enclosure or space for them to play
because otherwise one of the most common
things that happens with sugar gliders
is trauma they glide into a curtain and
they break a leg or they get strangled
they end up somewhere they're not
supposed to be and they get stuck they
get scratched they get hurt so you've
got to make sure you've got a safe place
for your sugar glider the other pieces
they're pretty sensitive little critters
they can dehydrate in a matter of hours
if they don't have access to enough
water they're also very susceptible to
toxins and so they eat a variety of
fruits and vegetables and if you don't
clean what you buy from the store well
enough you can actually poison your
sugar glider by giving them food that's
contaminated at levels that wouldn't
impact you or i but that do impact the
sugar glider so at the end of the day if
you're gonna have a sugar glider you got
to make sure you know what you're
getting into and you got to make sure
you partner with a veterinarian who can
help you make sure you're providing that
sugar glider with the right environment
and the right home and lifestyle to keep
them healthy and safe as long as
possible at nate hank zee
asks why are hedgehogs banned as pets in
new york city yet people keep finding
tigers in apartments you know taylor
swift has at least two full jaguars and
a goose now hedgehogs in particular they
are illegal in the five boroughs of new
york city the reasons are because number
one they can carry diseases that can be
transmitted to other animals foot and
mouth disease is the big one and number
two oftentimes exotic animals are
prohibited because if they were to
escape they could do significant harm to
the native wildlife in the area and
that's the case with hedgehogs in new
york city here's the thing exotic pets
are a handful you gotta be careful with
what you're getting into because they
have unique needs in terms of the
environment they need to live in so
whether t swift is doing it or not we
all should think twice or maybe three
times before we adopt an exotic animal
as a pet at colorful girl asks is cat
urine toxic
i think it is no i wouldn't recommend
drinking it i wouldn't recommend
injecting it but it's not toxic it's
just urine at el push
underscore old people 3 asks how do dogs
get cancer like i'm sorry but are they
smoking or something here's the thing
with dogs they get cancer for a lot of
the same reasons we do first of all
genetics they can just be predisposed
certain breeds are predisposed to
certain types of cancers for example we
know that german shepherds and boxer
dogs have a much higher likelihood of
developing a cancer called
hemangiosarcoma we also know that for
example dogs with short hair
can be more prone to developing
something called a mast cell tumor but
also just like us dogs are a recipient
of what's in the environment around them
so we know people sometimes get lung
cancer even though they never smoked a
day in their life same thing happens
with dogs they live in the household
where someone is smoking they're close
to contaminants or toxins think about
where a dog's nose is all day they're
down on the ground so we don't always
know why a dog gets cancer but what we
do know is they're exposed to the same
kind of environments that we are and so
the same things that cause cancer in
people can cause cancer in dogs
unfortunately okay for this question i'm
gonna need to call on the expert let's
call in jack jack come on
so at it's me lexi1 asks are you
supposed to brush a dog's teeth and the
simple answer to that question is yes we
find that about 80 percent of dogs that
come into our hospitals and 85 of cats
between the ages of 3 and 10 come in
with evidence of dental disease so jack
here is a great example of a dog who
will let you brush his teeth and it's
something that you can start with any
dog or a cat from a young age jack sit
good boy
so one way if you've never done this
before is to use a finger toothbrush so
what's important is we call it flip the
lip you flip the lip up you take a look
at their teeth and you do a gentle scrub
and then with bigger dogs or pets who
are used to it you can actually use a
special modified toothbrush that fits a
dog's mouth you flip the lip
and you go ahead and brush their teeth
to remove that bacteria and that that
early source of dental infection or
dental disease that we might find in our
own teeth the teeth provide a really
great surface area for bacteria to grab
hold and as they begin to climb up under
the gums they have really easy access to
the circulatory system and once once
those bacteria get into the circulatory
system they spread throughout the body
so here's the thing when it comes to
taking care of your pet's teeth the
reality is that they lead a shorter life
than us a more accelerated life and so
we should be taking care of their teeth
to the same degree as we take care of
our own if not even more the next
question from at pets q and a is what's
the best way to cut a dog's nail what's
really important is that you get your
dog used to having their nails trimmed
and this is something that you can start
with as a puppy because many dogs don't
normally don't naturally like to have
their paws touched so to cut a dog's
nail you want to look closely and
differentiate between the pink living
flesh of their nail and the white part
which is the same as the white part of
our nails as it grows out beyond the
beyond the blood vessels now this can be
much harder to do in a dog with a dark
nail and it's also important to
recognize that the more often you do it
the more frequently you trim their nails
the easier it becomes they that helps
the blood vessels to recede so you're
less likely to do what we call quicking
them which means that you've cut it too
short and you've actually cut into the
sensitive tissue but i can show you here
just a little bit where you find just
the tip of the nail
insert it through the trimmer quick trim
his are so short that all i'm having to
do is just scrape off the very edge of
them
make sure your dog gets used to you
holding his paws
and gets comfortable with that idea and
do it on a regular basis at yuba vet
tech posts a question of the day how is
heartworm spread and what is heartworm
this is a fascinating question because
heartworm is preventable it is extremely
serious if dogs and cats acquire it but
it is preventable so heartworm disease
what is it well it's a parasite that's
transmitted by mosquitoes the mosquito
bites a dog it picks up some baby
parasites they develop within the
mosquito and the next dog or cat that
mosquito bites gets that heartworm
disease those worms then spend about six
months living in that animal until they
take up residence in the heart where
they mate they reproduce and they
produce their own little baby parasites
when a dog or cat acquires heartworm it
is fatal unless treated it is treatable
in dogs although quite expensive and
quite risky it is not treatable in cats
so the end of the story we need to
prevent it this is a really important
question this year because we know that
because of
temperature and climate changes that are
expected in 2022 there will be a higher
incidence of heartworm so if you aren't
using heartworm preventative for your
dog and cat today go talk to your
veterinarian every pet should have
beyond heartworm preventative every
month of the year at gracerasner asks
why the hell would you declaw a cat do
you know what decline a cat actually is
it's amputation of the end digits of
their fingers to remove their claws and
that actually has been shown to result
in long-term chronic pain for cats who
have been declawed you know the
veterinary hospital that i work for
banfield along with many others
does not condone the practice of decline
cats anymore it does not generally solve
the problem it's intended to solve which
is cats scratching or clawing and it is
painful and harmful to the long-term
well-being of our cats so let's not
de-clock hats let's talk to veterinary
teams about what other options are
available for them at kj young428
asks the question what are the benefits
and negative effects of neutering a male
dog number one minimizing overpopulation
if they're neutered they can't reproduce
so we won't have unwanted puppies there
are a couple of other benefits one being
that neutering a dog causes some
behavior changes primarily important to
most pet owners is that it diminishes
their likelihood of roaming the other
thing that's related to that sort of
wandering behavior is that unneutered
male dogs are more likely to be hit by a
car that's really just secondary to the
fact that they're out wandering about
but there are a couple of reasons like
that that make it wise to neuter a dog
if you don't have any intentions of
breeding them at pet md asks what is
grain free pet food really logistically
grain free pet food means that the pet
food has taken traditional ingredients
like wheat and corn and replace them
with something like legumes or potatoes
so the food still has a carbohydrate
source but it's been changed from a
grain to a non-grain here's the thing we
really have to get at with this question
is is grain free actually better and the
reality is that what is most important
in any pet food is the nutrients that
are conveyed to the pet the fat the
protein the carbohydrates the minerals
the vitamins etc so what you want to
look at for a food is not whether it's
grain free or not but you want to look
at the overall nutrient profile and
definitely talk with your veterinary
team to find the right diet that suits
your pet's unique nutritional needs
atmosin rio's mom asks if i gave my
horse worm medicine in june but i do not
believe it was a good brand can i give
him another dose i think he needs it if
i can find any with all the weirdos
buying it humans should not be buying
horse medicine for humans it's for
horses if you dewormed your horse in
june and it's july for example you don't
need to de-worm them again horses
generally need to be dewormed in the
spring and the fall worst comes to worse
your vet can run what we call a fecal
examination on your horse's feces on
their poop on their manure and find out
if it does indeed have parasites and
need to be dewormed that's a foolproof
way you can cause harm by deworming a
horse when they don't need it because we
can actually cause resistance against
the medications that we use to de-worm
horses in those parasites that that do
exist in the environment so at survivor
kitty asks okay advice what's the best
way to get a cat to take its medication
without being attacked first of all if
you're lucky enough to have a dog or cat
that will take their medication and
their food make sure you talk to your
vet and get something that's suitable to
provide to them in that form they also
make some great treats that you can buy
over the counter that have little holes
in them that enable you to put a pill or
a little bit of liquid so you can give
your pet a treat as you medicate them
and many pets will take that some
require the use of a little more
intervention for example we make
something called a pill gun which helps
you to take the pill get it to the back
of your pet's mouth and kind of shoot it
in so that they swallow it without too
much resistance so if it's not working
talk to your veterinary team and there's
definitely alternatives out there so
those are all the questions we have time
for today but jack those were some great
questions weren't they yeah
[Music]